sorry to interrupt  how's it going what was the deal yet v  what are you doing here who is this  thought i'd drop by you know make sure  everyone's playing fair  who the [ __ ] is this  they call me v i don't give an ass  licking [ __ ] with it  for this morning  [Music]  [Music]  you and your big city dog  i just wanted to help  can't help but wonder what would have  happened if you did it  let's not get torn up now here you never  know if your bad luck has spared you  from worst luck  you charged into the lion's den to help  us feet  why because you listen to your heart  that's a rare thing especially out here  some things money just can't buy  speaking of money can't just leave it  sitting around  thanks for everything v so long